Das ist das Fragenlotto. Mit unverschaemten und harmlosen Fragen.
Die harmlosen Fragen sind gruen, die unverschaemten rot.
Du kannst dir aussuchen, welche du willst und musst nicht antworten, es ist deine Entscheidung.
Die unverschaemten sind gruen?
Nein, die Roten.
Kann ich dir auch eine davon stellen?
Das kannst du.
Hast du diese Fragen gemacht?
Ja.
"Was macht dich so einzigartig?"
Ich habe ein aussergewoehnliches Leben, aber jedes Leben ist aussergewoehnlich.
Mein Leben ist einzigartig, weil ich meinen Lebensunterhalt mit dem finanziere, was mir das Liebste ist.
Und es hoert sich vielleicht banal an, wenn ich es so sage, es ist die Wahrheit.
Und es ist fantastisch. Ich hoffe, es wird fuer eine lange Zeit so bleiben
Ich kann davon nicht genug bekommen.
Noch zwei oder drei mehr.
Du kannst blind ziehen..
Du willst nur die gruenen beantworten? Das ist ok.
Du bist ja schliesslich frueh aufgestanden, heute.
"Why have you always believed in yourself?"
Das habe ich nicht. Wirklich nicht.
Und ich denke nicht, dass irgendjemand das von sich behaupten kann.
Ich glaube, zu dem zu werden was man will oder ist, ist ein langer Weg.
Im Hinblick auf die Person und als Songwriter.
Wann waren die Momente, wo du dich gefragt hast, ob du den richtigen Weg gewaehlt hast?
Ich glaube diese Momente habe ich staendig.
Nach der langen Tour war es sehr wichtig fuer mich, in einer andere Stadt zu gehen und mich zum Schreiben abzuschotten.
Aber auch, um ueber genau das nachzudenken.
Wenn man solch ein Leben fuehrt, wie ich es tue und permanent darueber spricht, wo man war, als man das letzte Album geschrieben hat,
ob es vor zwei Monaten oder  zwei Jahren war?
Dann ist es wichtig, einfach anzuhalten und darueber nachdenkt, ob man das fŸr sich tut oder  deshalb, weil alle es von dir erwarten. Oder weil es eben das ist, was du immer gemacht hast.
Und das ist auch wichtig fuer mich, zu wissen wer ich als Person bin, wenn niemand was von mir erwartet.
Das ist fuer jeden wichtig, in ihrem Leben einfach mal abzuschalten.
Du sagtest, dass du manchmal nicht weisst, was du willst und was die Anderen von dir wollen, die Plattenfirma oder deine Zuhoerer.
Was ist dein Wunsch und was sind die Wuensche der Anderen?
Wir versuchen, da sehr offen zu sein bei der Zusammenarbeit, die wir haben.
Aber natuerlich wollen wir unterschiedliche Dinge.
Mir ist am Wichtigsten, mich als Songwriter weiterzuentwickeln, dieses verrueckte Leben zu leben und trotzdem noch ein Privatleben zu haben.
Etwas, was ich nur fuer mich habe. Die Ruhe und sich auch mal eine Auszeit zu nehmen.
Meine Plattenfirma haette es wohl am Liebsten, wenn ich einfach immer weiter und weiter mach.
Fuer mich ist die Musik ein Riesen Bestandteil meines Lebens. Fuer viele andere ist meine Musik ein Geschaeft.
Und es ist sehr wichtig, dass ich da nicht zu sehr darueber nachdenke.
Ich muss mich darauf konzentrieren, was meine Ziele sind.
Die letzte Frage.
"War dein Rockstar-Leben zu stressig fuer dich, oder warum hast du deinen Stil geaendert?"
Ich denke nicht, dass ich meinen Musikstil geaendert habe.
Wo ich als Kuenstler jetzt stehe ist sehr sinngemaess.
Es war ein natuerlicher Weg vom Start als Songwriter hierhin zu kommen.
Ich schreibe jetzt seit 15 Jahren Songs.
00:04:52.00,00:04:48.50
Die Geschichten, die ich auf diesem Weg erzaehlen moechte, aendern sich von Album zu Album.
Wenn ich eine Geschichte geschrieben habe, ist sie ein Song. Ich lege sie in einer Schachtel ab und geh weiter.
Als Songwriter, ja. Aber als Performer war es doch eine andere Musikrichtung, oder nicht?
Ja, das war es, aber ich denke, das kommt nur daher, dass ich zu dem Zeitpunkt so viel juenger gewesen bin.
Mein Geschmack, meine Faehigkeiten und alles. Ich habe die Sachen geliebt, als wir sie gemacht haben.
Und ich bin noch immer stolz auf viele dieser Songs.
Wir machten genau das, was wir wollten.
Dadurch, dass ich das gelernt habe, ist es nun auch einfacher fuer mich, mich zu entspannen, wenn ich ein neue Alben rausbringe.
Solange ich in dem Moment 100-prozentig sicher bin, dass das zeige, was ich will, kann ich in fuenf oder fuenfzig Jahren darauf zurueckblicken
und egal, was fuer einen Geschmack ich dann habe, weiss ich, dass es gut war.
Noch eine gruene zum Schluss.
"Warum bist du so schoen?"
Dein Vater, deine Mutter, deine Oma?
Weil ich schoene Leute in meinem Leben habe.
Du bist auch schoen.
Vielen Dank, du bist aber ein wenig schoener, als ich es bin.
Danke fŸr das Kompliment und dafuer, dass du hier warst.